bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'examen au sénat d'une proposition de
loi socialiste qui vise à faciliter
l'implantation d'infrastructures de
recharge de véhicules électriques dans
l'espace public en france on en parle on
en parle avec louis aujourd'hui
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur ump
maire de cagnes-sur-mer également l'un
des spécialistes du véhicule électrique
ici au sénat alors la france est plutôt
en pointe en matière de véhicules
électriques 14000 véhicules qui ont été
vendus l'an dernier en hausse de 50%
mais il reste un grand problème ce sont
les bornes pour recharger ses véhicules
et il ya de grandes inégalités
territoriales comment ça s'explique
selon vous vous avez tout à fait raison
la france est le premier marché de
véhicules électriques en europe le
troisième dans le monde donc nous avons
une industrie aujourd'hui qui a ouvert
ce champ là c'est une industrie
réellement et donc nous avons besoin de
soutenir la croissance de cette
industrie pour cela vous avez tout à
fait raison nous nous inscrivons dans un
contexte aujourd'hui qui est contrasté
il nous manque des bornes parce que les
bornes font partie des besoins est
indispensable pour faire fonctionner le
véhicule électrique donc il faut
accélérer la manoeuvre dans ce domaine
là il ya des inégalités sur territoire
sa légalité il ya des inégalités bien
sûr sur le territoire d'où le travail
qui a été fait déjà par les
collectivités locales qui est très
important avec l'aide de l'ademe et
notamment par exemple si vous prenez la
première métropole de france dont je
suis vice présidente je connais bien le
sujet nous avons là plusieurs dizaines
de stations d'autopartage qui ont été
mis en oeuvre
première fois en france en véhicules
électriques qui marche très bien et donc
on sent qu'il ya un engouement du public
pour autant ce n'est pas suffisant il y
a des grandes taches blanches et donc la
proposition cette proposition de loi
amène à exonérer
delano maniabilité public l'installation
de bornes sur le domaine public c'est
une proposition modeste mais elle a le
mérite d'exister elle va faciliter la
mise en place de ces fameuses bornes et
de créer avec le je dirai au niveau
national un réseau dit essentiel qui
permettra de trouver une borne
régulièrement c'est un texte qui vise
aussi à réaffirmer le rôle de l'état
dans l'importation de ces bornes à ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce rôle
primordial qui doit être accordée à
l'état je suis quelqu'un qui pense que
il y à une france unie et indivisible
que donc nous avons besoin d'un état
stratège l'état n'a pas à s'occuper de
tout mais l'état qui doit avoir une
vision du moyen et du long terme c'était
à la stratège me paraît souhaitable de
ailleurs aussi dans la domaine de la
réforme ferroviaire je défends un état
stratège bon mais l'etat sera cher doit
définir un cadre global doit veiller à
la cohérence et surtout surtout en
l'occurrence éviter qu'il y ait la
moindre fractures territoriales parce
que si nous laissons effectivement les
uns et les autres agir sans qu'il y ait
un cadre global nous risquons d'avoir
des zones blanches comme on a pu en
trouver dans les télécommunications
c'est ce que nous voulons éviter et donc
un relatif consensus sur cette
proposition de loi quels sont les points
que vous modifiez l'ump néanmoins par
exemple je dépose un amendement sur le
fait que
cette exonération de paiement
d'occupation du domaine public doit être
limitée dans le temps pourquoi parce que
j'y suis extrêmement favorable pour
faire démarrer la filière mais le jour
où la filière fonctionnera ça arrivera
dans quelques années 5 10 ans à peu près
à ce moment là il n'y a pas lieu
d'exonérer une filière qui aura en
modèle économique équilibré voilà donc
ensuite il y a deux ou trois motifs
d'inquiétude donc qui en consensus et
claire et au nom du groupe ump je
défendrai
je soutiendrai cette ppl mais je vais
demander au ministre de s'engager très
très clairement sur deux ou trois points
parce qu'il ya des inquiétudes donc je
les dis sur les zones blanches est ce
qu'il y aura risque de zones blanches si
c'est le cas cette maison ici qu'est la
maison des collectivités locales ne sera
pas d'accord ensuite vous avez la
tarification ce qu'il y à une
tarification diversifiée en fonction des
régions est bon ou est ce qu'il y aura
une tarification à peu près unitaire au
plan national bref nous avons besoin de
ces précisions et je lui demanderais
tout à l'heure en séance au ministre
pour avoir une confirmation de notre
soutien merci beaucoup louis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tout de
suite on prend donc la direction de
l'hémicycle c'est arnaud montebourg
arnaud montebourg pardon qui ouvre la
discussion générale
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le véhicule électrique est
un choix technologique mais c'est aussi
pour le gouvernement un choix politique
car c'est une révolution dont nous avons
décidé de se saisir qui est en marche et
dont nous disposons des possibilités
d'accélérer le cours est de faire en
sorte que la france se positionne comme
championne mondiale bien sûr européenne
elle est déjà mondiale elle est aussi
mais
lui permettent de l'être de façon
durable dans la compétition
technologique
de l'électromobilité
c est un point tout à fait sensible pour
nous car comme vous le savez nous avons
toujours jugé qu' en même temps que nos
constructeurs avaient connu des
faiblesses avait pris des décisions de
toutes natures sociales parfois
douloureuses
capitalistique parfois audacieuses mais
également des décisions
visant à l'innovation pour se réinventer
la stratégie de la france dans
l'investissement dans le véhicule
électrique est centrale et c'est le
constructeur national historique qui
n'est pas le premier constructeur
français qui renault qui en alliance
avec son allié mondiale nissan a décidé
d'y investir l'essentiel de son énergie
je crois que à la fois les modèles zoé
ou leaf renault nissan sont devenus
aujourd'hui
les pionniers les avant gardistes de la
révolution
du véhicule électrique
notre pays est déjà le premier marché
d'europe pour les véhicules électriques
et hybrides de nouvelle génération sur
lesquels nos constructeurs ont donc
cette avance technologique acquise
reconnu et au plan mondial le marché est
considérable car les ventes sont en
forte progression partout dans le monde
un rythme beaucoup plus rapide que celui
des véhicules hybrides qui se sont
historiquement imposé sur le marché je
voudrais d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière combattre le
pessimisme
plus ou moins en vogue sur la question
en expliquant souvent dans les colonnes
de commentateurs toujours avisé autorisé
que véhicule électrique ne décollerait
pas qu'il serait en retard je voudrais
combattre cette opinion en expliquant
que si l'on compare les courbes de
installation dans l'univers familier des
ménages d'europe et de france des
véhicules hybrides la courbe du véhicule
électrique connaît un succès éclatant et
il est intéressant que sur les
innovations technologiques depuis sion
rapporté des choux à des choux et qu on
ne compare pas des carottes des poireaux
et de ce point de vue là vous me
permettrez de dire que si l'on compare
l'installation des véhicules hybrides il
a fallu quinze années les véhicules
électriques commencent à s'imposer peu à
peu dans les flottes privé public et y
compris chez les particuliers il est
d'ailleurs intéressant de regarder ce
qui se passe dans des pays qui ont
investi un tout petit peu plus tôt que
nous comme les états unis une étude du
ministère de l'énergie a révélé que la
croissance des ventes d
modèles électriques dans les deux
premières années de vente est deux fois
plus forte que celle des modèles
hybrides à leur lancement aux etats unis
d'amérique et ces derniers ont conquis
en dix ans une part de marché de 3% le
gouvernement américain s'est donc fixé
un objectif d'un million deux cent mille
véhicules électriques en 2015 en europe
la croissance des véhicules électriques
connaît la croissance aussi très forte
l'agencé européenne pour l'environnement
indique que les ventes ont été
multipliées par vingt entre 2010 et 2012
d'après une étude réalisée par le
cabinet navigatrice search les ventes
mondiales de véhicules dotés d'une
technologie électriques hybrides
hybrides rechargeables et véhicules
électriques
totaliseront plus de 35 millions
d'unités en 2022 dans le monde je
voudrais vous donner le détail qui n'est
pas mince des premiers succès du
véhicule électrique et certains d'entre
vous seront surpris car le véhicule
électrique n'a pas la faveur de du
citoyen habitant les métropoles mais les
petites villes rurales dont vous êtes
ici constitutionnellement les
représentants car ce sont dans les
villes de moins de cinquante mille
habitants que renault vend
75% de saison et et dont la vente
continue sur un rythme soutenu
là où les transports en commun ne sont
pas suffisamment développés où les
trajets domicile-travail pendulaires ne
sont pas assez desservies et où les
citoyens nos compatriotes ont décidé de
réduire leurs dépenses de
carburant et il est vrai que le choix du
véhicule électrique est aussi une forme
de révolution non pas seulement
économiques technologiques à
l'investissement sur les marchés
mondiaux en termes de parts de marché là
où notre industrie automobile se
réinvente mais aussi une révolution
sociétale je voudrais vous en dire un
mot si vous me le permettez car une
société où
plus respectueuse de son environnement
qui permet des transports avec zéro
émission
de gaz carbonique sans aucune nuisance
sonore c'est à la fois essentiel pour
réduire notre dépendance aux ressources
fossiles mais aussi pour développer
notre souveraineté énergétique je
voudrais dire ici profiter de la tribune
sénatoriales pour indiquer à nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent et aux
revenus les plus modestes que c'est
aussi le moyen de se déplacer à moindre
coût
c'est le plein à 2 euros d'ailleurs
quand le prix de la batterie commencera
à descendre et à chuter en raison de la
diminution de son coût unitaire et son
développement technologique
le plein lui ne variera pas et le prix
de location de la batterie chez les
constructeurs mettant à la disposition
de nos compatriotes des véhicules
électriques lui ne baissera
c'est donc aujourd'hui un véhicule qui
est compétitif d'ailleurs nous avons
calé notre politique de bonus sur les
véhicules électriques de manière à les
rendre à rendre ses véhicules
compétitifs par rapport au véhicule
thermique de petite envergure de taille
modeste la 208 et la clio étant chez nos
deux constructeurs le modèle référentiel
nos maux d'une aux bonus pardon à
6300 euros pour les véhicules
électriques d'ailleurs ont passé nous en
sommes nous entamons la troisième année
de soutien et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le soutien de l'état dans cette
politique
de l'électromobilité permet à de
nombreux de nos compatriotes disposant
de revenus modestes de diminuer leurs
coûts de déplacement pour ce qui regarde
la faire avec scepticisme
je voudrais dire que
85% des français
parcourent moins de 65 km par jour donc
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir
des stations services électriques
partout et il est donc nécessaire de les
placer au bon endroit c'est un peu
l'esprit de cette proposition de loi de
manière à faire en sorte que chacun
puisse être rassurés sur l'usagé de son
véhicule électrique mais pratiquant
moi-même l'électromobilité disposant
d'une zoé de fonction je dois vous dire
qu'en plus du plaisir de redécouvrir la
conduite et la liberté
alliage de la nervosité de la douceur de
l'agressivité parfois du moteur
électrique mais aussi de la délicatesse
j'ai envie de vous dire que nos
compatriotes peuvent utiliser le
véhicule électrique sans aucune
difficulté car elle dispose de batteries
qui leur permettent d'accomplir le
double de ce qu'ils accomplissent chaque
jour en moyenne pour 85% e d'entre eux
je voudrais ajouter que en plus des
bonus que nous avons
décidé dans le plan automobile dès mon
arrivée au mois de juillet 2012 nous
avons un soutien très important au titre
du grand emprunt au prés nos
constructeurs équipementiers pour
développer encore la technologie si nous
avons semé tôt en oeuvre ce plan en
présence d'ailleurs de son chef
sont son porteur puisque chacun des
plans 34 plan industriel la nouvelle
fera industriels sont portés par un chef
de projet qui est monsieur le préfet
francis vuibert qui nous accompagne au
banc des ministres aujourd'hui
nous avons également un plan autonomie
et puissance des batteries visant à
reconstituer
notre souveraineté dans la maîtrise
technologique des batteries car
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des technologies
sont importés d'asie que ce soit la
corée le japon
par préférence à la chine d'ailleurs et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
avec le cea et le laboratoire du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives
nous avons fait le choix avec renault
nissan d'investir dans des technologies
permettant d'améliorer chacune des
briques technologiques sur l'ensemble
des technologies des batteries donc nous
investissons y compris dans la
technologie en un monde ce que les
constructeurs pourront sortir dans les
futures générations de batteries cela
donnera de l'emploi aux français et cela
fera plaisir aux français de savoir que
lorsqu'ils achètent une zoé ils achètent
une voiture fabriquée à flins avec des
moteurs fabriqué à cléon et cela fait
plaisir de le dire car renault dans sa
stratégie de réinvention de ses métiers
a fait le choix de relocaliser sur le
territoire national jusqu'à 700 mille
véhicules par an je rappelle que il ya
deux ans nous étions à 500000 il y a dix
ans étions à 1 million c'est donc une
remontée pour la base industrielle
france en matière d'automobile je ne
peux ici que m'en réjouir je évoqué
excusez moi après cette parenthèse un
peu improvisée la commande publique nous
avons aussi utiliser la commande
publique de l'état qui étaient
réorientés
à 25% obligatoire vers les véhicules
électriques et hybrides nous avions 100
véhicules électriques et hybrides en
tout en 2012 nous sommes passés des gens
en 2013 1270 j'espère qu'ils n'ont
encore avancé en 2014 je regarde les
mets mes collaborateurs de bercy en
fronçant les sourcils en disant qu'il
faut continuer cet effort
j'ai apprécié plusieurs de mes collègues
ministres disposent de minuscules
électrique je vois que le parc la flotte
de l'elysée maintenant est muni de zoé
bref l'esprit presse j'ai vu des députés
rouler en zoo et je n'ai pas encore
aperçu deux sénateurs le faisan mais
comme ce sont des petites villes de
moins de cinquante mille habitants je
suis certain que nous allons bientôt en
voir
alors qu'elles s'étaient une petites
taquineries si vous permettez mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs de manière à
vérifier que vous suivez bien le
discours ministériels
alors quel est le sujet de cette
proposition de loi d'origine
parlementaire venue de madame frédérique
massat députée de l'ariège c'est faire
en sorte que finalement la dynamique qui
est enclenchée en france puisse
s'étendre s'accentuer et être partagées
par nos compatriotes et que les
obstacles essentiellement psychologique
aussi parfois techniques qui peuvent
être sur le chemin du choix ou de la
décision visant à rouler électrique soit
supprimer c'est une demande de nos
constructeurs mais c'est aussi le choix
de notre plan industriel bornes de
recharge électrique visant à densifier
le réseau de bornes de recharge nous
disposons en france du plus dense réseau
d'europe avec 8000 points de charge nous
le devons essentiellement aux
initiatives des collectivités locales
qui ont soit elle même décidé
d'installer en régie directe tout en
étant eux mêmes les opérateurs de ce
programme et cette initiative des points
de charge mais aussi lorsqu'elles ont
délégué à des systèmes d'autopartage
tels que autolib à paris
à lyon ou à bordeaux ont permis par
exemple en région parisienne de disposer
de plusieurs milliers de points de
charge dans 40 collectivités communes de
la région parisienne c'est qui permet
aujourd'hui ça c'est une information
qu'il faut délivrer aussi au public de
façon plus pressante ce qui permet à
toute personne propriétaire d'un
véhicule électrique ne participant pas
au réseau d'autopartage d'utiliser comme
tiers utilisateurs les bornes de
recharge du réseau autolib construit par
sur délégation de service public
l'entreprise bolloré aujourd'hui il y a
donc suffisamment de points de charge
dans la métropole la grande mais de
grand paris pour permettre les trop
mobilité de se développer et notre
conviction est donc l'ensemble du
territoire national doit désormais être
mallet c'est la mission qui était
confiée à monsieur le préfet francis
vuibert avec qui nous avons travaillé
avec les députés et avec qui nous nous
apprêtons à conclure avec vous-même
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
souhaitons d'eau accélérer la
multiplication sur la carte de france
des zones équipées de bornes de recharge
normale ou accéléré
normal ces huit heures accélérée c'est
plutôt 4 heures deux à quatre heures
cela dépend des technologies à
l'initiative des collectivités publiques
ou du secteur privé beaucoup aujourd'hui
de supermarché la poste qui est un
établissement public mais
fonctionnant comme une entreprise privée
installe des bornes de recharge dans
leurs abords les gares sncf commencent à
se munir nous avons sollicité les
parkings souterrains les grandes
compagnies vinci et bientôt manière ce
que à l'intérieur de ces souterrains
parking nous puissions voir apparaître
un certain nombre de ces équipements
c'est d'ailleurs en ce sens que j'ai
demandé l'abaissement des seuils
d'éligibilité prévues au cahier des
charges de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt de l'ademe qui était un
obstacle à l'installation ou à l'accès
aux subventions du grand emprunt je veux
disposons une enveloppe de 50 millions
pour aider les collectivités locales à
procéder à ce type d'équipement le seuil
de 200 mille habitants va être supprimé
et remplacé par un seuil de densité fixé
à une borne pour 3000 habitants
l'arrêté qui valident ces modifications
et à la signature de monsieur le premier
ministre donc son entrée en application
est imminente et j'informerai le
rapporteur de ces évolutions manière à
ce qu'il puisse vous en informer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs 2
manière complémentaire il nous a paru
nécessaire de relier entre elles
l'ensemble des initiatives locales pour
leur donner une cohérence nationale
c'est l'objectif finalement teri tu un
ter territoriales qui justifie nécessite
l'intervention de l'état la cohérence
entre les initiatives il ya comme une
sorte de peau de panthère quand on
regarde la france sur les installations
de bornes de recharge
donc il s'agit finalement de coordonner
l'ensemble d'initiative les rendre
cohérentes et c'est ce qui justifie
cette proposition de loi discutée cet
après midi madame la députée frédérique
massat a pris cette initiative qui
permet d'ailleurs concrètement
d'exonérer du paiement de la redevance
d'occupation du domaine public
l'implantation de réseaux
d'infrastructures de recharge du
véhicule électrique et ce texte qui est
opérationnel pragmatique très concret et
sur une logique plutôt enclenche une
logique incitative est plutôt novatrice
pour ce type de projets
d'infrastructures nationales les
collectivités locales bien sûr
conserveront leur pouvoir d'autorisation
d'occupation du domaine public dans le
cas de la discussion concertée prévue
par le projet de loi et chaque commune
sollicité pour a bien sûr refusé
l'implantation pourra dire je
préférerais que ce soit l endroit plutôt
que tel autre et d'une certaine manière
nous n'envisageons pas
la mise en oeuvre de ce réseau sans la
coopération des collectivités locales
qui est essentiel et collectivités
locales connaissent les flux de
transport mieux que n'importe quel
opérateur en la matière et seront
éclairés la décision des opérateurs donc
cette coopération pourra s'exercer dans
le cadre légal que nous définissions
ensemble
cet après-midi le financement reposera
intégralement sur les porteurs de
projets
en contrepartie de l'implantation
puisque le financement de 106 finalement
lorsqu'un opérateur dire à moi je
souhaiterais que dans d'autres communes
monsieur le maire il y en a une dizaine
voilà les en droit d'imaginer tous
d'accord pas d'accord le maire dira là
je suis d'accord dans ce quartier là
vous trompez vous devriez réfléchir à ça
finalement tombent d'accord qui paye
c'est plus la collectivité locale mais
c'est l'opérateur parce que lui il y a
un intérêt national tout le monde est
gagnant et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons prié les élus locaux
d'accepter je crois que monsieur
pélissard le président de l'association
des maires de france que j'avais
consulté comme la massat nous en a fait
nous a donné son accord en contrepartie
de l'implantation la personne publique
concernée devra ne pas prélever de
redevances d'occupation puisque
finalement c'est un gain pour la
collectivité publique qui améliore
l'équipement de son territoire ce n'est
pas une perte sauf dé ce parce qu'elles
font volontiers concédé mais elle rend
service à ses concitoyens et finalement
l'opérateur lui-même ne voit pas ses
coups alourdi ce qui évite de se
retourner sur l'usagé du véhicule
électrique qui devra payer l'électricité
plus cher donc crois qu'on a là un
équilibre un modèle économique sur un
maillage national qui peut fonctionner
l'état bien sûr on a toujours besoin de
l'état ce n'est pas le colbertiste
assumer que je suis qui dirait le
contraire l'état pourra bien sûr exercer
un contrôle sur ces projets afin de
s'assurer la cohérence nationale des
projets portés par les entreprises
privées
les initiatives de collectivités locales
et les consortiums privés qui se
déclareront candidats pour mailler le
territoire et donc il y aura une
approbation des ministres de l'industrie
c'est à dire moi même et de l'écologie
madame royal et et l'ensemble pourra
évidemment faire l'objet d'un
accompagnement de l'état entré dans le
capital si nécessaire
selon les règles de l'investisseur avisé
je dis cela pour que nos amis bruxellois
nous entende ce texte s'il est adopté
facilitera l'émergence d'un maillage
national
c'est donc la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le gouvernement
soutient pleinement cette initiative
et le gouvernement lèvera les gages
c'est à dire qu'il compensera toute
perte éventuelle de ressources pour les
collectivités
qui est de l'état qui pourrait émaner de
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
parlementaire je voudrais saluer
l'esprit constructif
ici comme à l'assemblée qui a présidé à
vos travaux en commission sur l'ensemble
des bancs un grand merci particulier à
monsieur le sénateur jean jacques
filleul qui a animé les travaux de votre
champ les amendements qui ont été
apportées en commission apporte des
clarifications tout à fait utile au
texte tout en conservant à celui ci son
esprit de simplicité
le pragmatique qui était désiré par sa
conceptrice voilà comment nous pouvons
franchir un cap c'est très concret mais
ça sera très utile donc je ne peux que
vous remercier messieurs les sénateurs
de l'apport qui sera le vôtre dans cette
discussion
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jean jacques filleul
rapporteur de la commission du
développement durable
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est un petit texte qui nous
rassemblent aujourd'hui un petit texte
par la caille un seul article 3 alinéa
est un texte efficace d'autant que cette
proposition de loi aura sans doute
sans nul doute de grands effets monsieur
le ministre collègues de grands effets
car nous espérons tous ici que la
voiture électrique s'impose auprès d'un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens la
mesure proposée est simple elle est
politique aussi comme dit monsieur le
ministre elle est simple et techniques
mais nous aurions tort d'en sous-estimer
la portée nous sommes aujourd'hui face à
un tournant décisif un tournant décisif
pour l'avenir d'une filière industrielle
au sein de laquelle notre pays est
numéro 1
décisif aussi par notre capacité notre
volonté à nous engager pleinement dans
la transition énergétique en nous
appuyant sur un modèle économique et
industriel plus sobres en énergie
carbone et le véhicule électrique le
vecteur de tous ces objectifs sont
ambitieux comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rappeler devant la commission il n'est
plus ce qu'on a pris l'habitude
d'appeler le véhicule du futur non la
voiture électrique c'est bien la voiture
d'aujourd'hui il faut simplement tracé
le chemin
c'est la voiture qui permet premièrement
de créer des emplois et des métiers
nouveaux au sein d'une filière
industrielle d'excellence
inscrite parmi les 34 privilégiée par le
gouvernement d'autant que nous avons et
c'est un atout un gros avantage
compétitif avec des entreprises
d'envergure mondiale
tancé les constructeurs automobiles que
c'est les électriciens schneider legrand
et il y en a d'autres
deuxièmement de réduire
significativement nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et ajoute de réduire les
nuisances sonores puisque le véhicule
électrique est par essence si je puis
dire silencieux troisièmement de se
conformer aux exigences européennes et
de ne pas être en défaut par rapport à
la directive
directive relative aux carburants de
substitution
celle ci devrait être adoptée
prochainement elle prévoit que les états
membres se fixe des objectifs de
déploiement de bornes de recharge
électrique via des plans nationaux bref
nous sommes dans le sujet
malgré une montée en puissance
significative au cours de ces dernières
années le parc de véhicules etc restent
limités environ
25000 véhicules actuellement
c'est-à-dire 0 5% du parc global et en
dépit d'une augmentation des ventes de
50% entre 2012 et 2013 les premiers
chiffres de l'année 2014 ne sont pas
aussi prometteur il laisse entrevoir un
léger recul des ventes qu'il nous faut
donc enrayer sans plus attendre
pourquoi cette fragilité mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je crois
que les causes sont connues les prix
tout d'abord largement due aux prix des
batteries qui demeure trop élevé pour un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens mais qui
sera bientôt amenés à baisser avec ce
qu'on appelle l'effet de série et qui
bénéficiera des avancées de la recherche
il faut compter treize mille euros en
moyenne pour une voiture électrique
après déduction des aides
auxquelles j'ajoute environ 150 euros de
charges par mois en comptant la location
de la batterie les recharges en
électricité sans doute encore beaucoup
et faute de communication plus incisive
c'est surtout perçue comme moins
rentable qu'un petit véhicule thermique
au long des auditions
j'ai enregistré kylie a manifestement
des problèmes justement de communication
communication des constructeurs d'abord
sur les dix sept modèles existants de
véhicules électriques communication sur
les coûts ensuite puisque en réalité si
on compare au prix de revient d'un
véhicule thermique avec les pleins
d'essence il est souvent plus économique
d'opter pour une voiture électrique
d'autant que ces modèles sont robustes
et dur long je rappelle qu'il n'y a
pratiquement pas de maintenance et enfin
problème de communication dans les
concessions automobiles semble-t-il où
parfois les clients sont réorientés vers
des véhicules thermiques plus
rémunérateurs à la vente
j'ajoute qu'il ya un fait de société
évident nous n'avons pas encore intégré
la culture du véhicule électrique c'est
un défi sur les valeurs monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien compris que vous
voulez le relever et nombreux ici sont
ceux qui vous soutiennent il s'agit de
diffuser plus encore cette culture du
véhicule propre ainsi que ces nouveaux
comportements dans tous les secteurs de
la société il y à une bataille
culturelle a gagné mais pas que culturel
il faut aussi compter avec les
contraintes les freins technologiques et
la certitude vis-à-vis des évolutions
mais l'obstacle le plus important celui
qui empêche une vraie montée en
puissance des ventes de véhicules
électriques c'est l'absence d'un réseau
dense et structurée de bornes de
recharge électrique sur notre territoire
avec les difficultés avec cette
difficulté nous touchons là sans doute
le point dur c'est ce déclic qui
permettra à g le croit à la fois de
rassurer les utilisateurs
et de vulgariser ce mode de transport je
le reconnais il ya une grande part de
psychologie dans ce constat en effet on
sait que les batteries auront une
autonomie de plus en plus importante
elle est actuellement vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre environ 120
km en moyenne mais notre collègue en
commission à l'affiché par exemple
évoqué de nouveaux modèles renault
notamment qu'ils pouvaient tenir qui
pourront tenir jusqu'à 300 km
d'autonomie en août seuls 10% des bornes
de recharge qui sont d'ailleurs les
seuls concernés par la proposition de
loi concerne le domaine public puisque
l'essentiel des charges 90% se font
à domicile ou sur le lieu de travail
d'ailleurs pour stimuler les équipements
des particuliers et des immeubles
collectifs
un coup de pouce serait aussi nécessaire
sur ce sujet monsieur misys je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
piste de rendre ces points de charge
éligibles aux certificats d'économie
d'énergie
cette idée recueille l'assentiment de
nombreux collègues voilà je vous
interroge mais revenons à notre
proposition de loi malgré tout ce que je
viens d'énoncer beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne franchissent pas le pas
du véhicule électrique car tout
simplement ils ont peur de tomber en
panne loin de chez eux
il est donc urgent de lever l'obstacle
le président de la république lors de la
conférence environnementale en 2013 à
fixer un objectif clair que le pays soit
par tous équipés de bornes de recharge
d'ici 2015
quel est l'état du réseau aujourd'hui
vous l'avez rappelé mais il revient on
compte environ 8000 points de charge
installés ou programmés donc nous sommes
très précis 3760 points de recharge qui
ont été installés par les collectivités
territoriales sur les territoires ces
investissements sont soutenus par
l'ademe à hauteur de 30 ou 50 % en
fonction de la nature de la borne
accélérer ou rapide et
1500 points de recharge dont les
dossiers sont en cours d'instruction
justement par l'ademe on trouve aussi
les quelques 5000 points de charge
parisien autolib est aussi évidemment
des initiatives privées
ce réseau vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre et le premier d'europe et le
troisième au niveau mondial que toi nous
l'avons dit il n'est pas suffisant
j'ajouterai qu'en plus de ne pas être
assez dense ils ne constituent pas à
proprement parler d'un réseau puisque
toutes ces initiatives ont été prises
parallèlement sans véritable
coordination générale de manière un
petit peu anarchique en fonction des
projets d'où aujourd'hui de fortes
disparités
locales nous avons relevé par exemple
dans le poitou charentes et environ 2700
dix bornes d'installer et puis dans des
régions comme champagne ardenne ou
bordeaux où la bourgogne entre 30 et 50
bornes
le parc national de bornes de recharge
existant est donc très déséquilibré avec
des zones blanches très faiblement
équipe très faiblement équipés et donc
un risque de rupture d'égalité
territoriales le risque d'une nouvelle
fracture qui vient s'ajouter ou qui
viendrait s'ajouter à d'autres factures
comme la fracture numérique la
proposition la proposition de loi que
nous examinons qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale le 6 mai dernier
répond à cette insuffisance son objectif
est double accélérer le déploiement des
bornes de recharge et rééquilibrer les
implantations en assurant un maillage
national cohérent le moyen c'est
l'exonération de redevance pour
occupation du domaine public qui met en
place l'article unique de ce texte ce
texte de loi va donc tout changer
aujourd'hui seules les collectivités
territoriales peuvent installer des
bornes de charge électrique sur leur
propre domaine public et elles le font
avec l'aide de l'ademe
comme je viens de révoquer dorénavant
l'état ou un opérateur pourront aussi
installé des bornes sur le domaine
public des collectivités sans avoir à
payer de redevances sur ce point la
commission a adopté sur ma proposition
un certain nombre de modifications
visant à s'assurer qu'il n'y ait aucune
rupture d'égalité le texte de la
commission est désormais clair
pourront être en charge du déploiement
des infrastructures de recharge sur le
territoire des collectivités l'état un
opérateur qu'il soit public ou privé ou
même plusieurs opérateurs tous ces
schémas seront possibles la commission a
également étendu le champ de cette
exonération de redevances au domaine
public de l'état et celui des opci mais
le bénéfice de cette exonération de
redevance sera se met à plusieurs
conditions impératives première
condition l'état le ou les opérateurs
concernés devront présenter un plan de
déploiement
des deux bornes de recharge à
l'approbation des ministres en charge de
l'industrie et de l'écologie qui devront
en contrôler la dimension nationale qu'y
at il derrière cette notion de dimension
nationale
la commission du développement durable a
considéré que si un décret devait bien
sûr venir
préciser les modalités pratiques de
cette nouvelle procédure d'agrément par
les ministres la rédaction du deuxième
alinéa n'était sur ce point pas assez
précise il fallait lui donner un peu
plus de consistance elle a donc créé
écrit cet alinéa en indiquant qu'un
projet de dimension nationale
s'entendait d'un projet qui premièrement
se déploie sur deux régions au moins
j'insiste sur ce point il s'agit d'un
minimum
beaucoup de ces plans
concerneront sans doute tout le
territoire national comme j'ai pu le
voir lors des auditions des projets en
préparation chez des candidats comme
bolloré par exemple et deuxièmement dont
le nombre et la réparation et la
répartition des bornes assurerez un
aménagement équilibré du territoire la
deuxième condition impérative pour
l'état où les opérateurs candidats c'est
d'avoir soumis leurs plans de
déploiement à une concertation
rassemblant le porteur du projet les
collectivités territoriales et les
réseaux de distribution d'électricité
la commission a ajouté les personnes
publiques gestionnaire du domaine public
concernés dans les cas où il ne s'agit
pas de collectivités elle a également
supprimé c'est presque anecdotique la
mention des réseaux de distribution de
gaz qui ne sont pas concernés par ce
texte le dispositif prévu est ainsi
clair si le plan de l'opérateur réunit
ces conditions il sera alors validé par
les ministres et pourra être déployée
sans être soumis à redevance cette
exonération mes chers collègues sera un
plus pour les acteurs privés en effet
les entreprises qui deviendront
opérateur ne s'engageront pas avec ses
plans de déploiement dans des projets
rentables à court terme nous le savons
bien les bornes coûte en moyenne de
douze mille à 35000 euros ce sont des
investissements importants un véritable
pari industriel sur l'avenir nous devons
faciliter ces investissements via
l'exonération de la redevance
je crois que nous partageons tous cette
ambition quel que soit notre couleur
politique un s'inscrit dans le droit fil
des préconisations du livre vert de
notre collègue louis et je
voudrais souligner que la proposition de
loi a été adopté à l'unanimité de la
commission du développement durable je
voudrais enfin insisté sur un point très
important qui interroge des
collectivités territoriales mais vous
avez répondu pour partie monsieur le
ministre
cette possibilité donnée à l'état ou à
des opérateurs nouveaux ne fera pas
disparaître les initiatives locales
votre parole monsieur le ministre a été
entendu
d'une part en effet elles continueront
d'implanter sur leur propre domaine
public public des bornes de recharge
avec le soutien de l'ademe ces
initiatives devraient même montée en
puissance puisque l'ademe devrait
assouplir les critères d'éligibilité
avec par exemple une borne pour 3000
habitants
ainsi que des seuils de cours des
projets ramené à environ 200 milles
euros seul d'ailleurs 12 millions ont
été dépensés au c'ur l'enveloppent de 50
millions d'euros géré par l'ademe au
titre des investissements d'avenir
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez évoqué
peut-être pourriez-vous nous donner plus
de précisions sur cette faible
consommation de crédit d'autre part les
initiatives de l'état ou des opérateurs
ne seront pas en concurrence avec les
plans des collectivités elles
concerneront au contraire des zones où
les collectivités ne vont pas comme par
exemple les axes interrégionaux ou des
autoroutes
avec l'implantation de bornes de charge
rapide il y aura donc bien une
complémentarité bien comprise et c'est
l'ensemble de ces initiatives celle des
collectivités territoriales celle de
l'état ou des opérateurs et aussi des
les initiatives privées qui
constitueront le fameux réseau est
essentielle monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je crois que nous avons
là un texte équilibré et pragmatique il
permettra d'accélérer le déploiement sur
notre territoire de bornes de recharge
permettant à tous de faire le choix d'un
véhicule électrique quelle que soit sa
région je conclus en vous adressant
quelques questions monsieur le ministre
avez-vous des précisions sur les
candidatures qui se profile pour être
opérateur du déploiement des points de
charge et pour vous pouvez vous nous en
dire davantage deuxièmement nous sommes
nombreux ici sur tous les bancs je pense
notamment à certains de nos collègues de
la commission a regretté la formulation
trop restrictive du décret relatif aux
bornes écologique qui n'englobe pas les
cas de location longue durée ou avec
option d'achat allez vous
modifier le décret une question
importante
est attendue sur vous le maire ce
je vous remercie monsieur mini
ensuite l'extension du dispositif
d'exonération par la commission du
domaine public de l'état et des epc ye
est au bénéfice de tous les opérateurs
publics comme privés pourrait avoir des
conséquences financières pour les
collectivités locales mais vous nous
avez apporté les informations dans votre
discours je n'y reviendrai pas enfin et
c'est important ce dernier paragraphe de
mon intervention
enfin vous engagez vous à ce que l'état
prenne en charge lui même les zones
blanches qui ne seraient toujours pas
couvertes y compris après les un appel à
consultation des opérateurs c'est
important pour beaucoup nos collègues
que l'état s'assure de cette couverture
générale que l'on appelle la couverture
globale ou essentiel je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur renaud dantec
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous examinions aujourd'hui
une proposition de loi qui vit en
facilitant l'installation
d'infrastructures de recharge de
batteries les a développés donc la
filière des véhicules électriques et
hybrides rechargeables en levant un des
freins à l'achat de ce type de véhicule
la crainte de la panne sèche électrique
batterie à plat loin de toute prise le
développement du véhicule électrique est
une des composantes possible de la
mutation industrielle du secteur
automobile en cours nous le nions pas
même si parfois les écologistes font et
à mon avis à tort un lien entre le
développement du véhicule électrique et
le maintien voire la survie de
l'industrie nucléaire je crois qu'il n'y
a pas de lien et même on peut j'y
reviendrai faire aussi un lien entre
développement du véhicule électrique et
des énergies renouvelables
explorez donc le développement du
véhicule électrique est de bonne
politique
nous connaissons j'y reviens les
contraintes nouvelles qui oblige
aujourd'hui à une mutation rapide de
notre secteur automobile pollution
atmosphérique changements climatiques
raréfaction et flambée du prix du
pétrole
j'insiste sur ses obligations de
mutation ce serait je crois nous
fragiliser fragiliser nos filières
automobile que de les nier ou de céder à
la tentation de retarder ces mutations
sous le prétexte que le secteur serait
déjà trop fragile il est rare qu'on
sauve un malade en retard dans la prise
des médicaments l'histoire retient même
que retarder les échéances il ya
toujours à payer plus cher les mutations
industrielles voire de se retrouver en
situation de crack l'histoire un discale
française est pleine de ces désastres
liés à des dénis de réalité
si on observe le marché automobile en ce
moment on pourrait presque se croire
revenu au premier temps de l'automobile
en 1900 sur la voie publique on pouvait
croiser les voitures à vapeur d'amédée
bollée ou celle de serpolet peugeot qui
met au point la chaudière à
valorisations instantanée ou encore des
voitures à moteur à explosion allumage
électriques et refroidissement à eau ou
encore des moteurs à cycles
thermodynamiques à quatre temps
carburant au gaz par du carbure de
pétrole jared l'énumération pour y
passer l'après-midi c'était un moment
extrêmement créatif plus d'un siècle
après de nouveau nous sommes un peu dans
la même situation
plusieurs technologies sont sur la table
ou pour mieux dire sur la route et il
est probablement impossible aujourd'hui
de choisir parmi celles-ci laquelle va
sortir du lot pour se développer
massivement les véhicules thermiques
légers à très basse consommation la
fameuse voiture de litres au cent sur
lequel le gouvernement s'est aussi
engagé les véhicules hybrides les
hybrides rechargeables et électriques
cela moteur à hydrogène ou à pile à
combustible
j'arrête là aussi des numérations ce
foisonnement technologiques autour de la
voiture du futur appelle un soutien des
pouvoirs publics l'état vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre à avoir la jouer
pour orienter et accompagner l'émergence
du véhicule le plus adapté aux besoins
actuels aux enjeux futurs et cela dans
un contexte particulièrement fragile
pour l'emploi dans la filière sur le
territoire national nous le savons tous
nous sommes donc bien sûr un enjeu
absolument essentiel l'excellent rapport
de la sénatrice fabienne keller et du
député denis baupin pour l'opex insiste
d'ailleurs sur le fait je cite que la
voiture de demain existe d'accepter de
faire preuve d'imagination
ce qui signifie aussi qu'il ne serait
pas raisonnable de mettre tous nos oeufs
dans le même panier si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi l'état doit donc jouer
un rôle crucial pour coordonner la
recherche et le développement mais en
aucun cas se focaliser sur le soutien à
une seule technologie ce serait un
risque ou un pari pour reprendre le mot
du parc du rapporteur particulièrement
exagère rien ne dit en effet non plus
que l'électrique sera la solution de
mobilité individuelle à terme les
véhicules électriques pâtissent aussi de
plusieurs inconvénients propre autonomie
des batteries fort appel de puissance
électrique de recharge rapide pollution
causée par ces mêmes batteries
inconvénients qui se cumulent aux autres
défauts des voitures qui carbure aux
énergies fossiles la congestion des
routes l'énergie grise pour produire le
véhicule une question à se poser la
question à se poser pour être être donc
de se demander laquelle parmi l'ensemble
des technologies encore d'évolution et
la plus pertinente aussi selon le
secteur géographique le besoin précis à
couvrir concernant le véhicule
électrique et on le voit avec le
développent de son usage depuis
plusieurs années les âges partager
urbain semble aujourd'hui le mieux
adapté au regard des technologies
proposées en répondant à ces
interrogations ou en tout cas en ayant
une grille d'évaluation de ces
interrogations parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
non plus de répondre trop vite il faut
donc veiller à ne pas surdimensionner
les investissements au risque de
produire des coûts inutiles sur des
usages qui demain seront couverts par
d'autres offres techniques ou de
mobilité collective concernant l'objet
même de cette proposition de loi et
l'investissement dans un réseau de
bornes de recharge
je voudrais insister sur le fait que ce
réseau doit s'inscrire dans un réseau
intelligent la mutation du modèle
électrique en cours implique en effet le
déploiement de ces réseaux qui vont
mettre mieux en relation l'offre et la
demande entre les producteurs et les
consommateurs d'électricité et si le
véhicule électrique via à se développer
massivement il faut envisager que les
véhicules et les bornes soit en réseau
ceci permettrait notamment de moduler le
tarif des recharges selon l'offre
d'électricité afin d'éviter évidemment
que les véhicules électriques n'accentue
trop les pointes de consommation
électrique voire dans certains cas que
les véhicules servent de stockage
d'appoint épuise réinjecter de
l'électricité sur le réseau une voiture
utile même immobile c'est une utopie
intéressant bref s'il reste encore de
nombreuses prises de réflexion à faire
aboutir et des sauts technologiques à
produire cette proposition de loi va
dans le bon sens pour favoriser le
développement de cette filière mais vous
l'aurez compris les écologistes croient
la complémentarité des modes de
déplacement dès lors le soutien et les
investissements en faveur de la mobilité
durable doit se faire dans plusieurs
directions recharge des batteries
autopartage parking pour le covoiturage
aménagement des voies réservées
incitations diverses aux transports en
commun j'arrête là ma liste nous avons
besoin d'investir pour la mobilité
durera ce qui implique non seulement de
générer des flux financiers à
destination de ses investissements de
mobilité mais aussi une cohérence
d'action au niveau des flux financiers
la taxe sur les poids lourds est
évidemment un outil pertinent pour
générer des recettes affectées au
transport de demain et j'espère bien
nous aurons dans les prochains jours un
certain nombre de propositions et dannon
sur ce point le bonus malus
automobile également nous avions eu
l'occasion d'en discuter monsieur le
ministre dans cette perspective si l'on
considère que l'état doit accompagner la
mutation de l'industrie automobile dans
toute sa diversité
le bonus automobile doit répondre à
l'ensemble des enjeux il peut se lire
évidemment le développement du véhicule
électrique c'est ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui assez massivement mais il
doit répondre aussi à l'ensemble des
autres questions je pense notamment à la
question de la pollution atmosphérique
liée notamment au parc diesel
vieillissant là aussi le bonus malus est
un outil absolument essentiel il doit
être utilisé dans ce cadre c'est une
question de couette alors que le secteur
des transports est le premier émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre la réorientation
des transports vers la mobilité durable
doit rester la priorité c'est un pan
essentiel de la transition écologique
est une opportunité en termes de
création d'emplois et d'amélioration de
la qualité de vie les mesures à prendre
sont donc nombreuses et diverses le
texte qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui
constitue une partie de la réponse le
groupe écologiste votera donc pour cette
proposition de loi mais sans perdre de
vue que cela de cela n'a de sens que
dans une vision dansant il ne s'agit pas
de faire des coups mais d'avoir les
idées claires sur les calendriers les
usages privilégier la hiérarchisation
des investissements c'est notre
responsabilité collective de construire
cette cohérence
merci chers collègues voilà pour
l'examen au sénat de cette proposition
de loi socialiste qui vise à faciliter
l'implantation d'infrastructures de
recharge de véhicules électriques dans
l'espace public en france je vous
rappelle que la france est un acteur
important dans ce domaine c'est le
premier marché européen pour les
véhicules hybrides et pour les véhicules
électriques un marché en hausse de 50 %
l'année dernière avec pas moins de
quatorze mille véhicules vendus en un an
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité sénatoriale à 19h pour 24
heures sénat présenté par delphine
girard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires